earlier this year we covered a story out
of sanger texas about a grocery store
built
inside of a high school with a
surprising twist
they don't accept money the only
currency they use
is good deeds we were so inspired by
this story that we wanted to do
a follow-up and we may have
a follow-up on that follow-up and some
more surprise twists in store
but first take a look anthony love the
principal of linda tut high school joins
us now i'm very excited to meet him
welcome anthony
you have your students pay with good
deeds
what's your advice on what good deeds
are
that could be going above and beyond in
the classroom that could be
being a positive mentor or just a friend
to another student who's having a hard
time
there is no limit for the possibilities
or ways that schools can have a program
like this
we here at this show would just love to
get involved
i'm so personally inspired by
what you are doing i do see endless
possibilities
for your program and here we are
back with us again is principal anthony
love
hi principal love how is everything
going what's the latest and greatest
with your high school grocery store paid
with good deeds
so the store has been great students
i get all the all the time students want
to volunteer
or be a part of it somehow up to date
we've been able to help
close to 350 families which comes out to
a little more than 1500 people that
we've been able to help
with food insecurities
that's what i was going to say as much
as this is such a
poetic lofty brilliant way to bring out
the best in people
you're also helping people who are food
insecure i think what you're doing is
game changing in every way
and when you were last here you told us
that you wanted to see
good deed grocery stores replicated in
other school districts
and delayed middle school in louisville
texas heard about your story
and they wanted to follow in your
footsteps and we have the delay
middle school principal here chardee
dockery
principal dockery
principal dockery i'm so happy to meet
you
how do you think that a good deed
grocery store
could work and benefit inside of your
school oh
wow so delay middle school we're about
90
um economically disadvantaged which
means most of our students receive free
and reduced lunch
a lot of our families are living in
low-income housing
from trailer home communities to budget
suites and some of them are actually
homeless so they do not have
access to just kind of fresh organic or
healthy
healthy foods just within their you know
within their immediate community
and i just i saw a principal love story
and even the pieces on kindness and
and empathy and just servant leadership
our students definitely need that
experience because they
do not have those experiences out you
know in their communities and they don't
travel outside of their you know their
two mile radius often
principal love um do you have any advice
may i ask since you've done it
so you got to have a champion for the
grocery store you got to have somebody
who
who believes in it sees the vision and
you just have to have
a you know the mindset that failure is
not an option
there will be things come up that you're
not expecting
but you just have to have a team with
you that is there to
to support you and to support the
students
hmm that sounds like really honest and
real world
advice find the right people and
expect the unexpected there's not a
reference for this
and um we wanted to help turn this dream
into a reality and spread the love so
here to join us is catherine oliveros
the vice president
of community health improvement at texas
health resources
and they are the largest non-profit
health system in north texas and their
program has been going
beyond the walls of their hospitals and
into their communities
hi catherine thank you so much for
joining us today
thank you drew it's great to join you
catherine i was wondering if you
had something to say to principal
dockery
i do i am so excited to share some great
news with principal dockery
i'm pleased to announce today that texas
health in collaboration with albertsons
will be donating thirty thousand dollars
to delay middle school
so that principal dockery can replicate
the senior isd grocery store in their
community
thank you that is a blessing thank you
so much
we are so happy to be a part of this
principal dockery as a faith-based
nonprofit health
system texas health is dedicated to
providing quality clinical care
across all our access points so
congratulations
thank you thank you thank you so much
it's such a blessing principal dockery i
wanted to also let you know that our
friends at omaha steaks heard about your
story and they're also going to donate
another ten thousand dollars towards
your school's grocery store
thank you thank you oh that's not all
they're also going to throw in 4 000
worth of steak snacks for your students
and the staff at school
oh my gosh thank you so much
wow catherine thank you so
much for contributing to this program
you are
the seed of change um for this school
and principal dockery thank you so much
and to omaha steaks
who's also playing such a big part in
this and to principal love
you really are the genius that made this
all possible and i'm so
in awe of watching a potential domino
effect happen
and i'll do anything i can to uh
just be a part of that i think what
you've done
is incredible well thank you okay thank
you guys